Bangkok's street food is mouth-watering
here in Bangkok's Chinatown some of the
jewels of Asian cuisine are just a few
steps away for you to enjoy
right beside the street engulfed by the
myriad of smells and sounds of this
vibrant bustling metropolis but the food
is not only prepared and consumed in the
street much of what remains of it also
stays there that is one reason for the
recent decision to ban the trade almost
everywhere Street food has become one of
Bangkok's main attractions and that is
why in tourist areas like this one the
authorities will allow the vendors to
stay but in many other parts of the city
they're already gone
like in this residential area until
recently you would find food stalls on
the streets and sidewalks everywhere in
this area the vendors offered all kinds
of different dishes from the early
morning until late into the night but as
the authorities are eager to clean up
the streets make more space for
pedestrians and improve hygiene most of
the vendors here we're forced to pack up
and leave one of the few food stalls
that are still around is this one and
that's only because they managed to
squeeze into this little corner here
which belongs to a private property so
the operation is technically not on a
public sidewalk I know this place well
because I live right across the street
and I often come here for lunch
there used to be chairs tables and
umbrellas here for people to sit but now
all they have are these little stools
this is a family business and it
supports six people but now they're
struggling to make ends meet they're
making only half as much now as they did
before oh yeah got a dad car
we have to save money wherever we can
now but close on food also we can put no
more money aside before we could save
some of our earnings it wasn't much but
at least a little bit now it's basically
nothing even go mean are you lay out
there not gonna meet the customers
aren't exactly thrilled either what one
means one these ones in there are both
pros and cons it's good that the streets
are cleaner but now it's more difficult
to find cheap and good food well
personally I want street food to be
allowed because it's readily available
and cheap here I can get a proper meal
for less than a euro use my backbone
you're dying live in Hong Kong i'ma give
you - the sidewalks are there for people
to walk and not sell stuff I can
understand that but if they really want
to ban street food they should find
another area for the vendors to sell it
virat and his family still hope
authorities change their mind and
relaxed the rules on street food for now
they're still cooking so their business
can keep feeding them and their
customers as it has for more than 20
years